ein kraftwerk das durch eine kernfusion
unmengen an energie produziert das
könnte die lösung aller
energieprobleme dieser erde sein das
große vorbild die sonne
der traum vom forschungsteams weltweit
das kernfusion sex parlament wendelstein
7-x bei greifswald ist ein heißer
kandidat um neue spannende erkenntnisse
dazu zu liefern nach umbauarbeiten denen
die experimente jetzt in die heiße
phase
welche experimente genau in der
versuchsanlage geplant sind und wie
realistisch kernfusion den kraftwerken
in naher zukunft sind jetzt in klicks
und science fiction herzlich willkommen
ja fast anderthalb jahre war es nun
ruhig um das kernfusion sex peri mend
wendelstein 7-x bei greifswald nach
einer riesigen menge umbauarbeiten gegen
die experimente aber in diesem monat
september 2017 wieder los und zwar mit
vollgas in die entscheidende phase
fusions relevante plasmen mit einer
heizleistung von acht megawatt sollen
erzeugt werden tatsächlich doppelt so
viel wie bisher das plasma wird dabei
unvorstellbare 70 millionen grad celsius
heiß und soll nach den vorstellungen
des kreis walter forschungsteams zehn
sekunden lang stabil bleiben und hat
diesen bedingungen wollen wir plasmen
erzeugen die näher an die zustände
rücken unter denen in der sonne energie
aus der kernfusion von wasserstoff
klassen gewonnen wird was erklärt
institutsdirektor thomas klinger und
diese pläne sind tatsächlich
realistisch wendelstein 7-x gilt als
eine der modernsten forschungsanlagen in
diesem bereich der reaktor bei
greifswald in der vergangenheit schon
mehr als erfolgreich ende 2015 haben wir
darüber berichtet hatte das institut
mit der kernfusion anlage das erste
plasma erzeugt mehr als 1000 die
experimente folgten und elektronen
temperaturen von bis zu 100 millionen
grad celsius und ionen temperaturen von
bis zu 20 millionen grad überzeugten
dann am ende auch den letzten kritiker
und jetzt haben die techniker und
technikerinnen den reaktor in den
letzten monaten enorm aufgerüstet mit
einer leistungsfähigeren heizung
messinstrumenten und einem hitzeschild
unter anderem haben sie spezielle prall
platten auf grafit montieren so genannte
die welt touren
damit will das forschungsteam die
leistung der mikrowellen heizung auf 8,5
megawatt verdoppeln und eine höhere
dichte und temperatur des glas was
erzählen auch die sicherheitssteuerung
wurden überarbeitet genauso wie die
magnetfelder damit das passt mal optimal
eingeschlossen werden kann dermaßen
aufgerüstet könnte wendelstein 7-x im
dauerbetrieb funktionieren und so
vielleicht sogar den puls betriebene
fusions typ druckermarkt hinter sich
lassen und die geplanten experimente
sind wirklich mehr als spannend mehr als
100 forscherinnen und forscher aus dem
ausland haben vorschläge eingereicht
und sich qualifiziert verschiedene
themenbereiche sollen erforscht werden
unter anderem aspekte zur stabilität
des plasmas zum einschluss des plasmas
in den magnet ring und auch zur heizung
nach diesem ersten meilenstein sind dann
weitere umbauten geplant um in etwa drei
jahren klassen für eine dauer von einer
halben stunde aufzubauen das wäre
wirklich ein riesiger schritt dafür
soll die heizleistung langfristig um
weitere 2 megawatt erhöht werden unter
anderem durch
kohlenstofffaserverstärkte kunststoff
elemente die die bislang vorhandenen
graphit kacheln ersetzen sollen die
große frage die im versuchsreaktor
beantwortet werden soll wie kraftwerks
tauglich ist das design der anlagen des
typs der laudator hierbei wird das
plasma von einem kompliziert verwobenen
magnetfeld von den wänden ferngehalten
die ergebnisse sollen forschungsteams
weltweit dann bei ihren plänen weiter
helfen langfristig ein kraftwerk zu
entwickeln indem letztendlich
elektrischer strom gewonnen wird denn
das ist das ziel von wenn stein 7x ist
sollen alle vorarbeiten für den bau
eines kraftwerks dieses generator typs
geleistet werden und es scheint als
läuft hier wirklich alles nach plan
wir haben ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet die sonne ist das natürliche
vorbild für die kernfusion hierbei
verschmelzen die atomkerne von
wasserstoff und der sehr hohem druck und
hoher temperatur miteinander
dabei entsteht helium und riesige mengen
an
unsere zwei gesetzt deswegen wird die
kernfusion auch als die neue primäre
energiequelle gehandelt und könnte
tatsächlich co2 frei erneuerbare
energien ergänzen und ist dabei vor
allem viel ungefährlicher als die
aktuelle atom spaltung in
kernkraftwerken
hier kann es zu einer super
gefährlichen kettenreaktionen kommen
die unmengen an radioaktiver strahlung
freisetzt bei einem fusionsreaktor kommt
die reaktion beim unfall dagegen einfach
zum erliegen und die radioaktiven stoffe
die entstehen besitzen eine
halbwertszeit von jahrzehnten und nicht
von jahrmillionen die kernfusion wäre
ein riesenfortschritt hier bei pixum
halte ich das natürlich dazu auf dem
laufen wenn er kein video zum thema und
auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke hier geht es weiter mit die
kernfusion wird realität wenn stein 7x
hier geht es um das erste plasma das in
greifswald erzeugt wurde mit noch mehr
hintergrundinfos also nicht verpassen
und draufklicken viel spaß dabei und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran